c'était jeune hacker ce qu'il a fait
c'est un peu con car c'était que mon
cousin ah bah on se doutait bien
que je salue ces bombes à coke et que
vous saluer il est encore là donc oui et
il est comme moi c'est à dire
celui des verts à la vie
comment ça paraît comme un
cousin
mais moi le vélo de type
[Musique]
non
la voulait
[Musique]
j'adore ça fait plaisir que le foot se
sont pas ce qu'il en pense on n'est pas
évident est la star bien sûr bien sûr un
coût
de croisières devenues j'adore et
l'auditeur stiles adorent mais c'est
vrai on lui a dit mais en font des
coudes que ça non bien sûr biancheri
nous écoutent satirique pan pan pan et
autres
titres comme nous et c'est toujours à
l'avant ce qui met il m'a dit vous a
déjà dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tout à fait comme grosse bêtise alors
vous êtes avec votre cousin alain déjà
alain vous regarde il va être content
non c'est vrai cela parce que il est en
couple mais vous lui plaisez bucumi les
infidèles donc séparé oui ça avec moi il
n'ya pas de loi pas de souci à se faire
je précise qu'on était petit à petit
mais c'est à dire il ya deux ans non
plus mes gamins on était gamins et
j'imagine comme tous les gamins du monde
on comparer nos
îles à des jeunes
comme quoi le commis de rétrécissement
lui l'a fait dix-huit fois
la fête je suis commissaire au plan
mondial 1
on en reste à ce niveau là voilà la
bulle
[Applaudissements]
ça les battre et partex avait alors au
telegraph brain a dit ça commence bien
ça c'est donc avec ton cousin allez mon
copain nous ici là quand même dit ça
mais pas deux heures comparé décision
n'avait pas dopé leur dirai ça organise
un contrôle qualité
et non mais sérieux alors
oui et donc oui il me dit je m'en vante
pas tiens ton ça que c'est plus gros que
le mien non tu devrais
je pas non mais je me plante c'est vrai
que je sais que d'utiliser un autre
petit il était venu dans la famille non
mais à la maison on l'appelle à chaque
fois qu'ils arrivent à graines de
familles c'est à la petit zizi alors oui
il ya une autre famille le pauvre ne
regardait pas sûr ibos et du cou et du
coup magie ni comment pourquoi je tenais
ces élastiques et moi j'ai une idée on
était gamins les 5 6 ans j'ai une idée
qui à mon avis est élastique avec donc
il faut série si tu tire dessus et donc
nous allons dire et donc vous allez donc
un fake il ay la tâche et le dj d'alain
à une jeep
et donc oui non j'ai pas été aussi loin
et en fait on était donc j'ai pris une
pince à linge
j'ai tiré dessus une enquête sur une
petite corde est oui et s'il brillait
nos jours c'est vrai et maintenant mais
c'est grâce et c'est le cisi de votre
cousin alain qui a permis de faire lé
canard wc
voilà ah oui donc d'accord c'est ça en
famille en l'air qui est arrivé mais
attendent que j'embrassais 1 et kim et
qu'est ce que tu fais alain et belge de
l'ue agrandie le sexe non tu vas aimer
elles lui ont enlevé il pleurait
je vais enlever la pince à linge et sa
mère m'a mis une gifle non c'est vrai il
à faire c'est arrêter là s confusion
pour qu'on ne veut pas grandir insectes
bref c'est ça tu vas en revanche tout ça
pour ça on peut faire on peut faire
carrière avec un petit sexe
[Rires]
c'est quoi vous on savait si m rien de
comparer tout mamerow s'il vous plaît
son père s'il vous plaît allez c'est moi
j'ai tant ne pas aller mais il fallait
passer par les médias
et peut toujours tout ramener ces pistes
partout la halle et j'adorais les
j'adore il fait des gros pétards à mèche
la sent pas listé les faits si les
mammouths walla mois annie et en fait
j'ai rajouté crasse des prix minimes à
m'écraser pro tools c'est le canton de
trie
c'est connu c'est bourré les bostonnais
fribourg et les boîtes aux lettres le
gros pétard à l'europe et à mammouth
vous avez toujours été dans les pays
touchés et en fait j'ai foutu le feu à
tout le courrier mohlala gênant et le
plein de câlins dans le même temps
j'avais bourg et le feu là la cheminée
de ma grand mère ça s'apprend rien
et le même jour est donc l amie elle a
mis en route selon son son feu et là ça
lui a pété l'a fait une entrée très
grave alors ne ferai plus jamais je n'en
sais rien ah ouais ça le fait en fait
vous c'est compact très bon bah en fait
je ne ferai plus jamais bat à 50 euros
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous voulez qu'on est une sale histoire
grosse bêtise que vous avez fait il
verlaine alors moi j'ai été victime
d'une très mauvaise blague quand j'étais
jeune j'avais des années que
je joue au tennis avec un talent inégal
mais j'avais une particularité pendant
les cours je prenais des cours c'est que
je vous croyais sur un terrain de foot
donc je crachais les insultes et donc on
me pénaliser et un jour on m'a dit
puisque c'est ça tu sors c'était la fin
du cours tu vas aller dans le local
ranger tous les filets toutes les balles
je vais dans le local je range tout
matériel et mes collègues me pousse
dedans et m'enferme
j'essaie d'ouvrir la porte sympa ce
moment là je n'y arrive pas déjà une
victime je renonce et gérer la peine
déjà mort oui oui c'est un mercredi
l'été 16h30 me voilà pour fermer avec
votre voix vous avez pu faire rien pu
faire
ça dure des heures au bout d'un moment
qu'est ce que je fais je trouve un saut
je fais pipi dont lorsque j'étais
enfermé je commence à paniquer et le
soir j'entends gardien qui arrive le
gardien ouvre la porte et me dit mais
qu'est ce que vous faites là est en fait
la porte était simplement bloquée on m'a
accusé d'avoir fait pipi dans le seau
d'avoir voulu revenir voler du matériel
j'ai été suspendu trois semaines de
cours de tennis et ben je n'y suis plus
jamais retournés ils m'ont perdu alors
là vous nous avez perdu
[Applaudissements]